じゃ
方
こんにちははじめ社長です見ながら増え寒いですよねもう12月もだったんでさすがに
外だけじゃなくて室内にでも寒いそんな方何を使いますか
さあ全部4強あのーもう寒すぎるとさせる意味が顔料を使おうと思うんですけどもそれ
以上地球温暖化を進めたくない僕としましては
もう寒いときは全然使いますけどもエアコン以外の
方法で部屋を暖め方法はないのかそれをばかり考えて早26年が経ってしまいました
もう部屋内も17ととかなんですよ
あの
サメでねちょっとめっちゃ寒いんですけどもこんな寒い部屋を連絡を足せで温める方法
あるのではないでしょうかいうわけで今回はこちらの方達に協力していただきます
どうぞ
[音楽]
はいというわけでもと市の皆さんに集まっていただきました
[拍手]
部屋を暖め方法としましては一般的にみると
いい方なんですけど本当に失礼があった本に申し訳ないです
あの
ブーブーいいか do do
78というわけでみなさん光景体重が前にたくさんと産業0
ana
が抜けないからも皆降らせられるんですけども大きな全部集め変に出れば今説明猛獣
なんといっているくらいです
願望がなくてもいいんじゃないかという気がしておりましてみなさんで彼方音を温めて
くださいはいはいというわけでもう17個ぐらいですね皆殺というディッシュの皆さん
に失礼しました
連盟の皆さんに入っていただきましょうどうぞ
na na na
皆さん
この部屋を暖房ついてるけどやったねてもらえます今んところですか
首相政治的にくらいだ
でも汗がございますと
トゥデイ
あああっああ4パドゥ
ねっ砂で初です腰らくは9アンダーの3位に
南房のイオンでも23度が4度くらいだとか
carender
これこれ
皆さん19できましたわー
安部日が今92パーティー2
茅子やってました
はいえーなはい宇宙できますアーサー
jr 4番に入ったんですよ
noa そりゃあ
rar
ふーん
[拍手]
どんどんどんどん
20あの三者
me
rar
ああああああああ
妻21よらー
s 95 rar
んですよねやってくだされるワケ町2僕は卸ヨシ
10 high power
ああああああ
ああ
たぶんね迫力付落ち着きます
ブーブーああああ
ano hi ni
ここフィールド何度はでいいじゃん
中心月圧などでたらや弄んでなんかもうもう集まっ
女会で下さったらまあすごい熱気が
王者円陣組んだ24度言いました
ん
ああああああ
まあ皆さん25度行きました yeah
います
ん
ますはいああいう6度いきましたーーー
[拍手]
など ic 中ごめんねゾーンで中だけだ
あ
はい
27°逝きましたあああ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo おん
頃ん
ああああああ
par
あっ芽生えはレイズがん
me
teame
うううう
car
me あった
nan
ウォッチャーだけあぁそう
あなたはそうだから離さないんですよ10
モーセンうわあニッシュっ
ねうん
はいミュージア白い
[拍手]